I know
[Applause]
I know how can you not be excited when
the Winter Olympics know what started
listen if you're as excited as B you are
not very excited I know I shouldn't be
cynical the Winter Olympics actually a
great thing that all nations can come
together even the [ __ ] countries
ladies and gentlemen we we say we sent
Mike Pence to the Olympics he's there
though he's there now
doesn't like it foreigners playing in
the snow that's you know like I said he
he doesn't want to see Mexicans on ice
he wants to see ice on Mexico
and while you were sleeping last night
there was a government shutdown do you
know this again this happens America is
not like one of those mom-and-pop store
is where the odor just feels up when he
showed and feels like showing up
whatever the [ __ ] I was trying to say
[Applause]
but there was no shutdown because PT we
made a budget we have a budget--
okay the yearly deficit now not the debt
that's the accumulation of all the
deficits that's like 20 trillion but
just in one year now one trillion
dollars I don't want to be and I told
you so but you knew this was gonna
happen when you elected Hillary I mean
Republicans [ __ ] man I mean no shame in
their game when when Obama was president
and spending needed to happen they
fought every goddamn penny but they
opened right up to the white guy in DC
that's called the reverse Kardashian
[Music]
and of course Republicans you know this
about them they're great for coming up
but do really just pull a rule out of
their ass and it's like it's always been
there the new rule for them so for the
dead is as long as you claim
but you hate this with every fiber of
your being you can go ahead and do it
they have the same rule for gay sex and
collusion and of course most of this
money is urgently not needed by the
military that's where it's gonna go
trump Alevis quotes today said we love
our military we gave them everything and
more yes that's why he's known as the
master of negotiating but the government
the government is open on the White
House can get back to the important
business of hiring wifebeaters they've
been following this Rob Porter guy at
the White House okay
oh yes and Trump now is mad again a
general Kelly you know general Kelly his
stone-faced chief of staff
I call him general on electric
apparently he should have vetted this
guy Rob Porter a lot better and
everybody at the White House is like
well I didn't know it was around for a
year that these accusation
his Secret Service code name was Floyd
Mayweather you know Trump always on the
right side of it issue
he sprang right into action he told this
Rob Porter guy said I want your
resignation letter on my makeup table in
the morning you clean out your Chris
Brown's he said your brass knuckles and
get out of here
this guy's a Mormon a Mormon domestic
abuser what's that like to the planet
Kolob Alice fans of The Honeymooners you
gotta love that man audience but tell
also the interesting dig is Robert
Porter whatever the name is is was
dating hope Hicks you know hope picks
the 29 year-old chief of communications
there at the White House and toe pics
used to date Trump's campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski and there is rumors
that Corey Lewandowski actually dropped
the dime on Rob Porter for stealing his
woman tune in tomorrow for another
episode of all my douche bags it's like
the west wing meets clueless and over on
Celebrity Big Brother is coming out soon
and in the previews Omarosa it's a talk
to you - what are the other housemates
that she gets into tears when the person
says what's it like over there at the
White House and Omarosa says it's not
going to be okay it's so bad less than a
year over there and they turned her into
Marlon Brando in Apocalypse Now
[Applause]
but of course when amorosa said that the
White House took the high road and did
not comment I'm [ __ ] with you of
course they had to go tit for debt I
love it with the White House press books
but said Omarosa said was fired three
times on the apprentice this was the
fourth time we let her go yes if only
there had been some way to predict that
she wouldn't be working out and then to
top off this utterly splendid week
Donald Trump told the Pentagon that he
wants a military parade yes America
raagh wha is gonna do the tanks in the
streets thing oh it's gonna be
spectacular tanks and missiles and
fighter jets all presided over by a
loose cannon
this is this is scary stuff I mean this
has come up before they've asked we
don't do this no president does this
Republicans Democrats in the 1950s and
the height of the Cold War they wanted
ice in there a lot of people in an
Eisenhower to do this and ice never said
no we're strong that would actually make
us look weak but Trump is not Eisenhower
Eisenhower for one went bald naturally
he didn't comb hairs from his nutsack
updates on his hand
did you see Trump's bad hair day today
this is look at that
[Applause]
yeah
what I always thought the head here came
from there if it's not there where is it
coming from this is why he doesn't come
down until 11:00 a.m. do you know this
the tweet started six in the morning he
doesn't get to the office till 11:00
what is he doing that whole time his
hair
seriously Fox and Friends he watches his
stories and does his hair that's who
your president is a guy who'd put does
his hair all morning and then puts on
his face which he keeps in a jar by the
door